نذهب الان الى متابعه مراسم عقد القران
والزفاف كذلك ايضا في حفل زفاف ولي عهد
الاردن الامير حسين بن عبد الله نتابع
معكم الان من الصور المباشره من قصر
الزهران حيث
يستقبل الان العهد الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني وكذلك الملكة رانيا المدعوين
للاحتفال في هذه المناسبه من الغسل
والشخصيات ايضا من كافه العالم والمجوين
في احتفال كبير ايضا يقيم العهد الاردني
الملك عبد الله الثاني الليله حفل الاعشاب
في الديوان الملكي بمناسبه سفر ولي العهد
الاردنيه الامير حسين بن عبد الله حسب
المعلومات المتوفره سيحضر هذا الحفل اكثر
من 4000 شخص من كافه اطياف المجتمع
الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني والملك
راني في استقبال المهنيين المدعوين لهذا
الحفل الكبير في قصر زهران
القصر التاريخي الذي بني
بخمسينيات من القرن الماضي يعتبر هو القصر
الملكي الرابع بعد الغدان القصر الصغير
وكذلك عثمان في منطقه تعتبر من الاحياء
المهمه ودبلوماسيه في غرب العاصمه
الاردنيه عمان قد شهد هذا ايضا القصر عدد
من حفلات الزفاف الملكيه
في ذلك حفل زفاف ايضا ملك الاردن الملك
عبد الله الثاني والملك رانيا وكذلك حفل
زفاف الملك الحسين بن طلال والاميره منى
سنتابع معكم اذا مراسم حفل الزفاف والذي
يعني
عده مراحل ايضا شهيده هذا اليوم هذا القصر
سيتم فيه توقيع عقد القران بعد ذلك
سيتوجه وللعهد الاردني
وزوجته الى قصر الحسينيه في الموكب الاحمر
ربما بعد ذلك
وبعد وصول هذا الموقع بالموكب الاحمر سيتم
الاستقبال ايضا بواسطه مجموعه من الخياله
وحرس الشرف وفرق من المشاه الاردنيه ثم
سيتجه بعد ذلك العروسان وسط زفه اردنيه
تقليديه
و ينضم ايضا على المنصه الملك عبد الله
الثاني والملكه رانيا وكذلك والده العروس
لتحيه المدعوين
الذي يصل عددهم كما ذكرنا اكثر من 4000
شخص
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات